Okay, I'll give the talk.
So, I'm going to start off in the right way.
So I hope you've had a fruitful day.
I do not say happy, but I hope it has been happy.
Namo dasa bhagavato arahato sama sambodasa
Namo tassa bhagavato arahato samma sambuddhasa Namo tassa bhagavato arahato samma sambuddhasa Homage to the Buddha, the Blessed, Noble and Fully Self-Awakened One.
So we're looking at this, the Greater Discourse in Gozinga.
We've been there before.
You might remember that the Buddha approached three Arahats and asked them how they lived so well together, so peacefully together.
So this is a case of the Gosingasala tree wood.
Sala was the tree under which the Buddha was born and under which he died, I'm pretty sure.
Anyway,
There are a group of the elder monks here, Maha Moggallana and so on.
And Maha Moggallana rose from meditation, went to the Venerable Maha Kasapa and said, friend, let's go and visit Venerable Sariputta and listen to the Dharma.
And eventually they've got a group of monks, which includes Venerable Kasapa, Moggallana, Sariputta, Revata and Ananda.
So they all come together to see Sariputta and Sariputta puts this question to Venerable Ananda.
Friend Ananda, the Gosingasala wood is delightful.
The night is moonlit, the sala trees are all in blossom and heavenly scents seem to be floating in the air.
There's a bit of aesthetic joy.
What kind of, it's got Bhikkhu, but to make it our, to make it good for us, we'll say meditator.
What kind of meditator could illuminate this Gosinga Kala Sala Wood?
And Ananda says, a meditator has learned much, remembers what he has learned and consolidates what he has learned.
Such teachings as are good in the beginning, good in the middle and good in the end.
with the right meaning and phrasing, and which affirm a holy life that is utterly perfect and pure.
Such teachings as these he has learned much of, remembered, mastered verbally, investigated with the mind, and penetrated well with view, with understanding.
And he teaches the Dharma to the four assemblies, so that's the monks and nuns, laywomen and laymen.
with well-rounded and coherent statements and phrases for the eradication of the underlying tendencies, the old taints.
So according to Ananda, what would illuminate any place, what would make a meditator illuminate any place they are would be their understanding, their intellectual understanding of the Dharma and the ability to teach it.
So Venerable Ananda has spoken according to his own inspiration and then Sariputta turns to Revata.
Revata says, a meditator delights in solitary meditation, takes delight in solitary meditation.
He is devoted to internal serenity of mind, does not neglect meditation, possesses insight and dwells in empty huts.
So Revata,
who is the foremost of meditators, by the way, according to the Buddha, just wants us to meditate and try to find some empty huts.
So I'm sure you've all got an empty hut at the end of your garden or something.
So then Sariputta turns to Anuruddha and he says, with the divine eye, which is purified and surpasses the human, a meditator surveys the thousand worlds.
Just as a man with good sight, when he has ascended to the upper palace chamber, might survey a thousand wheel rims, so too with the divine eye, which is purified and surpasses the human, the meditator surveys the south thousand worlds.
So according to Anuruddha, we should develop the powers, these extraordinary powers.
So then he turns to Maha Kasapa.
Maha Kasapa was the one who led the convention after the Buddha died of the monks, of all the Arahats, where they decided what scriptures to remember.
And he was known as a bit of a fierce man, as you will see.
A meditator is a forest dweller himself and speaks in praise of forest dwellings.
He's an arms eater himself and speaks in praise of eating arms food.
He's a refuse rag wearer and speaks in praise of wearing refuse rags.
So remember in those days, they would even take the rags off the dead bodies, the corpses that were laid out on the charnel grounds.
He's a triple robe wearer and speaks in praise of it.
So if you're keeping the veneer very, very strictly, you should only have three robes, the lower, the upper,
and the double robe, which is for cold nights.
He has few wishes and speaks in praise of fewness of wishes.
He is content and speaks in praise of contentment.
He is secluded and speaks in praise of seclusion.
He is aloof from society and speaks in praise of aloofness from society.
He's energetic and speaks in praise of arousing energy
attained to virtue himself speaks in praise of the attainment of virtue attained to concentration himself speaks in praise of concentration attained to wisdom himself speaks in praise of the attainment of wisdom he has attained deliverance and speaks in praise of the attainment of deliverance he's attained the knowledge and vision of deliverance and speaks in praise of it now that's that's a that's a tall order so if somebody
Somebody who lives really very basically out there in the forest.
You could do that, I suppose, in the garden and spends their lives trying to become fully liberated.
All these people, all these monks, by the way, are liberated apart from Ananda.
Ananda is not liberated.
So now Sariputta turns to Moggallana.
And Moggallana was the second disciple.
So Sariputta, Moggallana,
the two main disciples of the Buddha.
What Moggallara suggests is that two meditators engage in the talk of the higher Dhamma and they question each other and each one and each being questioned by the other answers without foundering and their talk rolls on in accordance with the Dhamma.
Now this, the word there is Abhidhamma.
Now the Abhidhamma itself is the third
of the baskets.
So we talk about the Tipitika, there's the Vinaya, there's the Dharma, there's the discourses and the Abhidhamma, right?
And the Abhidhamma was obviously developed later, but even during the Buddha's time, there was an attempt to systemize it.
And you can see that at the end of the long discourses.
So according to Moggallana, that's what we should be doing.
We should be discussing the finer details of the Dharma.
Now, Sariputta now, Moggallana turns to Sariputta, and Sariputta says, a meditator wields mastery over his mind.
He does not let the mind wield mastery over him.
In the morning, he abides in whatever abiding or attainment he wants.
to abide to and to abide in during morning at midday he does the same and in the evening and then he gives a metaphor supposing a king or a king's minister with a chest full of variously colored garments in the morning he would put on whatever pair of garments he wanted to put on in the morning and so in the midday and so in the evening so too a monk
A monk or meditator wields mastery over his mind.
He does not let the mind wield mastery over him.
So that's Sariputta saying that we should be in control of our heart-mind.
Remember the word that's being translated here is citta, which refers to the combination of the heart and the mind.
So we should have mastery over it, you see.
Anyway, having had this discussion,
So let's just go over that.
So they were in this beautiful wood.
The night is moonlit and the sala trees are in blossom.
Heavenly scents seem to float from the air.
And according to Ananda, we should learn the Dharma and we should try and teach it.
And according to, where are we, Anaruda,
uh which we should be um we should be meditating all the time that's right excuse me solitary meditation and according to um what's his name where is he i've gone to anurudha i've lost my place here and i'm getting all confused where's his name cast uh anurudha yes uh we should be developing the powers according to um
Mahakasyapa, we should be living very sparsely and in the forests, devoting our time to meditation.
According to Moggallana, we should be talking to each other about the finer parts of the Dharma.
And according to Sariputta, we should be in control of our minds.
So now they approach the Buddha, you see, and they tell him what they've been talking about.
And then Venerable Sariputta asks the Buddha,
Venerable sir, which one of us has spoken well?
So they want a bit of praise, I suppose.
So the Buddha says, you have all spoken well, Sariputta, each in his own way.
Hear also from me what kind of monk or meditator would illuminate this Krasinga Sala Wood.
Here, when a meditator has returned from his alms round after his meal, he sits down, folds his leg crosswise,
sets his body erect and establishing mindfulness in front of him resolves.
Wait for this.
I shall not break this sitting posture until through not clinging, my mind is liberated from the taints.
So now this of course is what the Buddha did right at the end of all that training, where he came to a position where he thought, look, it's now or never.
And he went to sit under the Bodhi tree, the religious fig tree,
And made that determination that either he would crack this problem or die.
And he sat there, it seems, for six hours.
And lucky for him, lucky for us, he made it.
So that's the Buddha's advice.
And what the commentaries say is that all the previous ones are really relating to people who've already made it.
For the Buddha here is talking about somebody who hasn't made it.
and the determination needed to make it.
So that's the discourse on the Maha Gosinga, the great Buddha Gosinga.
So I hope you found that somewhat inspiring and that you will, of course, make this great effort to sit from now on until you're fully liberated and we can start shortly.
Very good.